Tracy's in Idaho hey Tracy how are you
I'm good thank you
good your question for John today how
can we help so I'm a huge fan longtime
listener his little background my
husband and I started our debt free
journey in 2018 for 100% debt-free
except for the mortgage we have three to
six months we have our life insurance in
place and our will we paid off $40,000
in 18 months and live on one income and
now invest just my income for retirement
my question today is in regards to our
18 year old son who moved out in sorry
I'm gonna try not to get emotional who
moved out in 2019 he didn't want to live
with us he didn't wanna live with our
rules or guidelines morals values
structure she's been living with a
family for the past year that pretty
much let him run amok get to school just
kind of be his own thing he's 18 even
though he's a senior in high school so
as a parent how do we move forward with
it she won't communicate with us return
phone calls text messages we're getting
a lot of outside influence right now
from just people that know us family and
we're just questioning where do we go
from here we have a small college fund
for him where I'm sure he's gonna
graduate and we have our will in place
and we've written it kind of with some
guidelines if he wants to come back into
the family and be a part of our family
there's some dates and ages where he
would inherit different amounts you know
we're just confused as parents where do
we go from here that's so painful yeah
that hurts so Tracy what did he step
away June removed out he ran away
basically in May Mother's Day weekend
and we called the cause and and we
brought him home forcefully and then in
June 5th 2018 he left and never came
home he did break into our home twice to
get him he's never had a face-to-face
conversation with us been to June
regarding any of this I am in counseling
my husband's been in counseling but
we're trying to work on our side
but we don't know how to move forward so
I think there's a couple of term yeah I
think there's a couple of things you can
do right now and then I'd love
here Dave's wisdom on the long term
financial planning I think you're gonna
have to you have other kids in the home
- we don't he was the youngest of four
we have kids from 13 he'll be 19 in July
we have kids from 32 to 19 and two
grandkids
does he have a relationship with any of
his other brothers and sisters nope he's
cut them all off okay any addiction in
his life
we suspect we've never had that
conversation with him okay so it's gonna
be a straight-a student
I mean his junior or freshman sophomore
year straight-a student his fall
semester straight-a student his grades
started taking spring of his junior and
he's barely passing I'll tell you what
you hold on through the break here when
we come back we need to take a little
bit of time with this and then not try
to answer it 15 seconds for you we're
talking with Tracy dr. John Delon he
joins me this hour OMG personality and
their 18 year old moved out and is
living with another family and has shut
off communication with them pretty
extreme situation and that's about how
far we got in the discussion you bet so
Tracy first and I just want to come in
here that you love your kid and that you
love your husband and the gel are taking
the steps to heal yourselves and to try
to get wrap your head around what's
going on here so here's a couple of a
couple of thoughts here number one it's
gonna be very important for you and your
husband to grieve the loss of the
picture you had painted for this young
man
and that's a that's a hard the only
thing harder than that is actually
losing your son and when you grieve this
loss a foundation of this grief is that
you and your husband gonna have to do it
together and so if you're seeing
separate therapists for separate reasons
that's that's your business but you're
gonna have to come together either with
with a family therapist or the pastor
that you trust okay and grieve together
because what happens is people grieve
differently and then you start comparing
grief and then you end up way further
apart than when you started this kind of
stuff can drive a wedge in a marriage
that's right so you have to be hyper
intentional about staying plugged in and
connected with your husband and that
means y'all gonna have to be graceful
with one another as you grieve the loss
of this and then start to develop a new
picture that's going to be more geared
to
the reality that you face the second
thing is is you're gonna have to let
your son know that you love him and that
he's always can come home but you're not
gonna give him a dime and you'll pay for
that yeah we haven't since October
we haven't Socktober good and that's
that's gonna test your soul like few
other things will and when you when he
burns up the couches that he's sleeping
on and then he moves on to the next
place in the next place everything in
you is gonna say go run and rescue him
and so here's the issue that the parents
are saying that they're the safe place
that we are the bad home sure and they
found that out from anyway you take
people in yeah that's right and when my
sister comes over we call her aunty
Aloka when aunty Aloka comes to the
house and she gives my kids as much gum
and Twinkies as they want man they love
her for a few days right and then when
she look at leaves we have a like a
cleansing process both both physically
and psychologically and we love it when
she comes and she spoils him rotten but
that's not long-term right so this is
going to have an expiration date on it
and the the important thing is that
y'all are there when he turns around
right but not not at his beck and call
and not feeding whatever things he
stumbled into and making sure you and
your husband are connected United in
this yeah that's a big deal that you
guys take connected and then and and
here's the thing there's all these
geniuses out there that will tell you
things like what Jon just told you is
tough love know what Jon just told you
is love it's not love sometimes has a
lot of strength to it to hold someone
you know tightly or to let them go or
whatever it is it takes a lot of love to
do that so you know what you're going
through is very very difficult and your
that what John said about the two of you
being on the same page and not caring
what everybody else thinks the other
stupid family or your relatives or your
friends who all have an opinion and
they're mostly wrong
you just can't you're not really
gathering input from the community at
this point you've got to get aligned on
what you guys believe to be right
with the help of a good coach a good
counselor and then lay out some steps
that say okay the boundaries have been
violated and for you to return here are
the you know here's what it's going to
look like you're always welcome under
these circumstances and you know if you
break in my house again I'm gonna put
you in jail okay you're not gonna do
that and if you're gonna come around
here you're gonna be respectful
you're gonna abide by our values and you
know I you know I got told one of my
teenagers one time you might be willing
to talk to your mother that way but no
one talks to my wife that way and so you
know it's that kind of a thing where
you're just saying this is who we are
and if you want to come around here this
is who we are and that's not gonna
change and we're not gonna suddenly
allow you to smoke pot in the downstairs
bathroom just because that makes you
happy and the other family allowed that
our values haven't changed and so this
is who we are and we love you and we
miss you dearly and we're hurting
because of this but that now as far as
the money goes again you guys can do
what you want but I think that boundary
is a current situation we're not going
to support which john said in any way
and you know i'm going to have a clause
I have causing my will today that my
grown children if they decide to go off
the ranch and one of them is gonna do
cocaine and live on the back of a yacht
somewhere with our money I don't think
so and so we don't have a lot of money
but we're we're just like we can't we
can't we were the same we have the same
beliefs we can't contribute to his
lifestyle exactly that's exactly what I
don't want to fund his insanity mm-hmm
with my dad while I'm alive or when I'm
dead yeah because I love him too much to
to come alongside and support his bad
decisions and leaving him in the will
does that so taking him out of the will
is not punitive it's it again is
actually an act of love because if we're
doing cocaine and you leave them two
hundred thousand dollars that means
they're gonna die mm-hmm I'm probably
gonna die anyway for doing cocaine but
for sure gonna die if you leave the
money to overdose and so why would I
leave a cocaine addict to $200,000 if I
love them that's how we would not we
felt I mean he's got some guidelines if
he wants to come back around when he's
25 if we were to die today I mean our
younger daughters executor she knows
what it says he you know and she's in
control but if he doesn't want to even
engage with his sibling or his nieces
and nephews then by time he's forty if
he still hasn't come around we basically
left it to his kids no let's say you
know I mean that's and I don't know I'm
people are like well love is love if you
love him it should be equally divided no
that's not true I can't do that right
now
no no no that's an inaccurate statement
that's a toxic bs statement that that's
a that is not love that is wimping okay
a supporting if I don't if I don't
really care about someone I will support
their misbehavior or if I don't care
about my kids I'm gonna I'm gonna do the
same things for both of them whether
it's accurate on one and it hurts the
other right yeah you know love is love
so I'm gonna leave the heroin addict
enough money to kill himself
that's a dumb but statement well it's
not love no it's not
so whoever says that is now prohibited
from giving me any further advice you
know whoever said that is prohibited
from giving me you're no longer I no
longer have this conversation with you
you're an idiot you know that's what I
goes through my mind I've got people in
my life that have parts of their life
that is so bizarre that I don't have
conversations with them in those subject
areas because it's not going to go well
so there's not a good reason to have
that conversation I'm just not going to
talk to you about this because you're
stupid you know and I'm I don't say that
but that's basically a boundary I put up
with people in my life you know I've got
some a friend that's spiritually gone
bananas just nuttier than a fruitcake
you know and so I'm not gonna engage in
that if he wants to you know but he
doesn't get to speak into my life
because he's off the ranch
I don't ask I don't ask that you say
this often I don't ask broke people for
their their insight about money right
exactly exactly and so but I mean once
someone makes a statement that's
inconsistent with the direction you're
taking in the you and
husband to believe you to be correct
then you can love them but I'm not gonna
have these conversations you you lost
your right you lost your vote in my life
on this subject because you're being an
idiot and so that that you know this
this idea that you're gonna make all
those kinds of people happy hmm you're
not but the boundaries here that maybe
that's the statement of somebody so
codependent oh man
that they can't breathe they in it you
know what that's I think it's a great
point you know who doesn't get a vote on
in about their feelings in my life my
two kids they don't get a vote
because my wife does and I've given her
that permission to have a vote on how
we're gonna solve some of these
solutions in our house but I've got a
thirty year view and a forty review in a
fifty year view of the young man and
young woman that we're raising and so
I'm not gonna take a short term a short
term easy way out and say sure sure sure
we're playing a long game on this one so
kudos to you and your husband to stay
connected on this one and always look
for opportunities where you can connect
with your with your son I'll give you a
prediction by the time he's 25 this will
be over no he's back he's back yeah yep
prodigal son will hit the bottom find
himself in the big stop